Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday
and in a stunning turn of events I find myself in an airport.
So I've got this 7-year-old son
and every Saturday he wakes up at 5 in the morning
and watches 2 hours of Pokémon
before I can even you know, like, get up and take the iPad away from him.
He has all the Pokémon encyclopedias and all these Pokémon cards
I don't even know where he gets them from,
I think he trades for them on the schoolyard playground?
And it's great, y'know, I want my kid to have passions,
I want him to be excited about stuff
but I know nothing about Pokémon.
Well, aside from what Henry has told me
and a brief foray into Pokémon Go,
so today I though I would explain the world of Pokémon
from the perspective of someone who has never seen Pokémon.
Alright Hank, so we all know that the last 500 years
have seen this huge decrease in biodiversity on Earth.
Well, good news!
In the near future, we get a big influx of species
and not just any species, like cute, cuddly, awesome, talented species!
They're called Pokémons.
How did they arrive on Earth?
I have no idea, was it like an alien world Noah's Ark situation?
Nah, probably not 'cause a bunch of Pokémons are based on current Earth like forms
like Horsea is, you know, basically a seahorse.
So maybe it was like a radiation event,
point being, there's like hundreds, maybe even thousands of new species.
You can catch them by using these things called Pokeballs,
like you throw a Pokéball at a Pokémon
and the little Pokémon ends up inside the Pokéball,
and then you put the whole contraption into your backpack.
Why would you capture all these Pokémon?
I mean why do people do anything ultimately?
Like why do people fish?
So you catch all these Pokémon and then you train them
so that they will be excellent in battle.
Wait, I forgot something important!
Sometimes you catch like too many of one kind of Pokémon
like you've got 17 Pidgeys and you don't need 17 Pidgeys and it's weighing down your backpack.
In that case I believe you can transfer your Pokémon
to someone called "the professor",
but this seems like it's maybe not a good idea.
I don't really know what he does with transferred Pokémons
but I asked Henry about it once and he said,
"Dad, Pokémons do not like going to the professor."
Right, so your job as a Pokémon trainer is to train up your Pokémon
and make them strong so that then, they can do battle with other people's Pokémons.
From what I can gather, it's basically like a Roman gladiator style thing
but, you know, for children.
Also, they don't fight to the death, they fight until they "faint",
but that's not tricking anyone.
Like Henry explained to me,
"Dad, 'fainting' is what Pokémons call dying."
And I was like, yeah, no, I get it.
So you catch Pokémon with your Pokéballs,
you train them up, you take them to battles,
and then you fight to the 'fainting' against other people's Pokémon.
And as far as I can tell, that's it, like it's basically just a sport?
It doesn't seem like winning Pokémon battles helps save the world
or make it a more fair or just place,
but then again, you know, neither does soccer, and I like soccer!
"The game", as Tottenham Hotspurs fans like to put it, "is about glory,"
which is to say that, you know, in the scheme of things, the stakes are very low.
That said, there's a lot of questions I don't have the answer to,
like how do Pokémon evolve? I have no idea.
If this is identical to fishing, why not just fish?
And, most importantly, given that most Pokémon are based either on legends (like Charizard is a dragon)
or on actual animals (like Rhyhorn is a rhinoceros),
what is Pikachu?
He seems to be just our collective idea of adorable
that we throw balls at and then put inside of a tiny spherical cage in our backpacks.
Which is weird, but I guess it gets less weird when you consider that that's our relationship with many non-human animals.
So Hank, that's my best attempt to introduce the Pokémon universe
from someone who knows nothing about the Pokémon universe.
Alright Hank, I have to go get on an airplane, I will see you on Friday.